[Aplausos]
es bueno buenas noches
no soy el gran orador soy cocinero así
que traje mis mismas
pues
por si no saben estamos a 500 pasos del
golfo de méxico este gran marc esa gran
extensión de mar que hoy tenemos
y para que tengamos idea de esa
superficie tan grande que está frente a
nosotros
el majestuoso estadio azteca que habría
casi 28 veces 28 millones de veces en
ese pedazo de agua
aquí nos estamos sentados el foro boca
que abría 286 millones de veces mi casa
una casa de infonavit con alberca para
36 casas que habría millones de veces
pero no venimos a ver quién tiene la
casa más grande y cuántas cosas les
caben al
al golfo de méxico
lo que venimos a hablar el día de hoy se
trata del mar
y sobre el mar déjenme decirle algo en
el cual todos estamos involucrados
tenemos un problema
no sé biólogo no soy científico un
investigador
pero no hay que hacerlo
hay que tener de título para nos cuenta
en la problemática en la alcoba
hoy estamos envueltos
soy cocinero y gracias a dios'
veracruzano
pasé varios años cocinando por las
mejores cocinas de europa recorrí todo
el mundo
desde hace 4 años regresé a veracruz
abrí mi proyecto
con la firma idea
de poder mostrar el mejor producto para
cruzando ante el mundo y yo creo que uno
de sus productos tendría que ser el
pescado
y cuando tras el proyecto mi único amigo
no es entonces alvaradeño por cierto
me dijo el mejor pescado del mundo está
en veracruz y la verdad en ese entonces
pues no podía contradecir
sabía que uno de los ingredientes más
importantes y casi obligados en el
restaurante tendría que hacer el pescado
así que me di a la tarea de buscar el
mejor de veracruz
busqué provee y pregunte a las
pescaderías y me llame con la sorpresa
que conseguía mejor pescado en ciudad de
méxico que aquí en veracruz me frustré
demasiado porque mi idea de restaurante
era tener el mejor producto en el mío y
no lo logré entonces
le hablo a mi mejor amigo ezequiel
hernández parte del éxito del
restaurante se lo debo a el oceanólogo
de profesión amante del mar este brother
tiene
más de su vida dedicándose al océano y
comercializando pescado a lo mejor
restaurantes de mexico
entonces pues quiere mejor que ver para
ayudarme a conseguir el mejor pescado en
veracruz
ezequiel me dijo me enseñó que el
pescado no era malo
desde que me mostró que lo que estábamos
haciendo más era el proceso
y me dijo mi eric hay dos mecánicas
la primera es la red y el palangre con
palangre la red pueden ser líneas de los
que no haya tenido oportunidad de ir a
pescar
anímense es increíble ya la única la
única vía silvestre que nos queda por
cazar
son líneas de un kilómetro dos
kilómetros y qué pasa con eso que pasa
con líneas de uno a dos kilómetros
cuando el pescado va a estar muerto son
doce horas en el que pescador va deja
las líneas y regresa dentro de dos horas
entonces va a subir un pescado ahogado
estresado magullado con el ácido láctico
ya descomponiendo la carne los coágulos
de sangre ya están en la proteína
entonces el pescado en un hermano era el
procedimiento en el siguiente caso era
el del anzuelo que hoy en día muchos
pescadores lo tienen todavía
y es el suelo lo que hace es es uno por
uno va sacando uno por uno pero sin él
iba el pescadito era un balde con agua
tibia por supuesto o directamente a la
lancha se imaginan y son jornadas de
pesca igualitas que la de un palangre en
sol 12 horas imagínense se sube el
pescado de un pescadito y que le pasa el
pescado que lleva dos horas muerto
cuando va a llegar a la playa va a tener
14 horas muertas en los rayos del sol
imagínense que le pasaría a un pedazo de
carne un peso de pollo con 10 horas de
en el sol yo no me lo comería entonces
pasaba algo similar
a los juguetitos estos
y ahí viene el primer problema es la
falta de técnica pero bueno tampoco
debemos de culpar el pescador
gran parte de este movimiento que hoy en
día vivimos
o que estamos sufriendo mejor dicho
siempre tú era el pescador el pescador
el pescador el pescador pero por qué
culpamos a una persona por no saber
tampoco está mal no saber
entonces para obtener un mejor sabor
combinamos la manera de pescar cambiamos
la manera de pescar nos quedamos sólo en
los pescadores que se acaban con el
suelo y decidimos sacar solo con el
suelo
intentar o pusimos la técnica de
desangrado y enfriado a bordo que le
pasaba ese pescadito
ese pescadito aprendimos que sacándolo
vivo en el mar lo dejamos va a perder un
90% 80 no fue científico 80 por ciento
de sangre
y aunado a eso vamos a batir su
temperatura el aguanieve esa temperatura
el pescadito le vamos a bajar a 2 grados
en 6 8 12 15 minutos dependiendo del
tamaño entonces ya tenemos dos factores
para que la calidad del pescado fuera de
exportación una no tenía sangre tenía
menos sangre por supuesto
las décimas notar en la proteína
2 la temperatura que está baja 2 grados
y teníamos que mantenerla así entonces
ya teníamos el pescado de exportación
el bonito
creo que hoy en día es de mis pescados
favoritos mi familia mis hijos no les
gusta creo que son y con pescado que nos
gusta pero el bonito fue el primer
pescado que comí con esta técnica el
sabor el brillo la textura es increíble
en verdad que es increíble firmeza de
pescado
y yo decía porque este tipo de pescado
no tiene precio en el mercado
lamentable y tristemente este pescado y
para los que vivimos en costa y somos
aquí ese pescadito no lo pagaré más de
15 pesos
y al pagarlo en 15 pesos nosotros lo
etiquetamos con un pescado corriente
me entristeció saber que un pescado tan
increíble como el bonito no era valorado
como otros
en ese momento se dijeron
un buena preguntas para las dos más
importantes fueron porque es un pescado
corriente
2 porque el romano es más caro que otros
pescados cuando para mí en temas de
sabor
instrumentales este es más fuerte y rico
que un romano
y me llevo a otro problema la falta de
valor para por igual
que todas las especies y la respuesta
estaba de nuevo en la falta de
conocimiento pero ahora se le suma la
economía del pescador que la verdad
a nadie nos interesa cómo le van a los
demás y eso lo que yo diga más campos
pesqueros el pescador sufre como
cualquier otro oficio
por otro lado nosotros no conocimos y me
incluyo cuando llegue a veracruz no
conocí a más de dos especies de pescados
las personas no conocíamos más de 30 a
40 especies diferentes y de esas seguro
habíamos probado menos de 15 por otro
lado tenía la realidad del pescador que
era pescar lo que le era dinero para
llevar sustento a su familia
imagínense si te pagan 15 pesos por kilo
de un pescado tienes de dos sopas o más
por los pescados caros o vas a sacar
bastante pescado del barato y te aseguro
que ninguno de esos escenarios
le va bien el mar
y me di cuenta y me llegó el golpe de
realidad
que todo romanticismo sustentable
sostenible responsable se acaba cuando
padeces hambre y eso lo viví y lo he
vivido en los campos pesqueros
entonces lo que decidimos es o hicimos
cambiamos la forma de comercializar el
pescado
qué pasa con eso nosotros ya no poníamos
estas especias te cuesta tanto lo que
hicimos es que vamos a pagar tres formas
al pescador pagamos como pesca chica
pesca mediana y pesca grande y que
pasamos con esa hora sin y bonito tenía
precio en las grandes ligas lo logramos
si todo pescado era excelente no tendría
que haber decisión de precios ahora solo
me hacía falta encontrar la manera de
mostrar a la gente la diversidad
infinita de pescados que hay y que no
sólo locos y que no sólo cocinar a los
que ya conocemos
para lograr esto soy cocinero para
lograr esto me regresar a la cocina y se
me viene mucho la frase se viene mucho
la frase perdón qué
escuché un en japón de los cocineros que
decían no hay malos pescados
habemos malos cocineros
entonces empezamos a servir la pesca
aprovechando todas sus características a
cada pescadito le pondríamos una
preparación diferente o lo seríamos
crudo lo seremos asado al horno al vapor
tratábamos de aprovechar todas sus
características y potencializar las en
una preparación hoy en día
he probado cocinado servido en mi
restaurante es más de 120 especies de
pescadito
me di cuenta que el problema para
encontrar el mejor pescado de veracruz
nunca fue el pescador el cocinero y
mucho menos el comenzar el verdadero
problema estaba en la desinformación ya
que si no sabes es un desinformado o
eres un ignorante y para ser honestos
volvemos a lo mismo no está mal no saber
pero si sabes si no actúas entonces eres
un cómplice
lo que empezó con una simple búsqueda de
mejor pero del mejor pescado de veracruz
terminó siendo un movimiento de cambio
cambiamos
pero se me quedará un poco la voz y
cambiamos la forma de vivir de 30
familias de pescadores que eso se ve hoy
en día reflejada en billete
cambiamos la mentalidad de más de 800
cocineros en todo méxico que no exigen
róbalo huachinango consumen lo que el
mar les da
cambiamos el chip
en noviembre mi restaurante hace 4 va a
ser va a ser 4 años si los quieres pero
cambiamos la forma de exigir al comensal
de pedir calidad y no exigir
especies son casi 15.000 personas y eso
te lo dice el sistema no llevo las
cuentas
cambiamos la mentalidad de una gran
parte de la industria restaurantera
local una vez una plática que escuche
decía
piensa global y actual local y yo cuando
llegue a veracruz lo que primero que
quise hacer es que me conociera todo
méxico y cuenta cosas pero no enfócate
en estoril y entonces empezamos a
cambiar lo más importante veracruz hoy
en día la gran mayoría de los
restaurantes en veracruz te sirven lo
que el mar les ha ya no llenan sus
congeladores de cuatro especies que es
normalmente demandamos consumen
directamente al pescador consumen y
consumen lo que el mar les dan pero
sobre todo cambiamos un poquito el mar
hoy los pescadores nos cuentan que ven
especies que ya casi no veían ya casi no
había pelo y ahora empieza a ver por qué
porque al no exigir una o dos o tres
especies dejamos que el ciclo de vida de
vida funcione mejor
increíble parece que sea de otro lado
parece aquí aquí en estos pasos
iremos al mar
de ahí venimos y desgraciadamente la
basura ahí termina
y bueno ya para cerrar este si no lo
estudie entonces si lo tengo que leer
una vez dicho esto les quiero dejar un
mensaje final
reconcilia con su cocina y con su forma
de comer
sigan su curiosidad y pregúntense de
dónde viene su cosita su comida comparta
su conocimiento hoy es el momento de
accionar a favor del mar ustedes como yo
somos parte de eso
háganlo todos los días por lo que más
quieran y estoy seguro que juntos desde
la cocina haremos un cambio 3
[Aplausos]